it is time to go
and take every last scrap with them
this young boy has never known another
home his family clearing out the place
they've lived in
for 21 years with no clear idea where
they'll go now
we are homeless now we do not know where
to go or where to live
now children in armenia are crying they
want to go home
it is very hard such sorrow
they are an armenian family from the
kalbajar enclave in the north of
nagorno-karabakh
and they are the losers in this
russian-led scramble for peace
why has putin abandoned us
they could stay but they do not want to
live with azerbaijanis as neighbours
they don't believe even the russians
could keep the peace then
they would rather destroy the homes
they're leaving
in the end we'll blow it up or set fire
to it
i'm not leaving anything to muslims
and so the houses burn the smoke
billowing across kalbaja
a symbol of the enmity between these two
peoples
both of whom now in two respective wars
have won and lost
lost and won this land
russia has deployed close to two
thousand peacekeepers to
nagorno-karabakh and the territories
around
it to keep the two sides from fighting
again
as azerbaijan gets ready to move its
citizens back
to territories it lost in the last war
26 years ago
in the armenian capital yerevan there is
a sense of betrayal
they want prime minister nikola
pashanyan to go they believe he should
never have signed this truce
but what choice did he have the army was
demoralized
sick with dysentery and coveted out
gunned and in retreat
no match this time round for azerbaijan
emboldened by turkish support
this russian brokered truce has stopped
the bloodshed but it cannot extinguish
the hate
as armenians say goodbye to their homes
they know
they are still a long way from peace
dana magnay sky news moscow